une petite pique aux candidats qui dans
toute l'île masquer leur manque de
supporters dans leurs meetings en
invitant amis et alliés politiques
d'autres communes
le mpf est aux commandes depuis 25 ans
au françois
et c'est un jeune qui assurent la relève
alain claude lagier 46 ans était
directeur de cabinet de joseph losey et
c'est lui qui a été sollicité par le
mouvement pour mener la liste
c'est bien c'est beau le voile est levé
des fonds soient réunies aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
l'homme est un administratif et il se
dit aujourd'hui sans ambition
personnelle
oui sans ambition personnelle lorsque
vous êtes au service n'avait pas
d'ambition personnelle j'avais une
ambition pour votre ville pour votre
peuple pour la martinique
mais personnellement ma vie ne se limite
pas à un engagement politique
j'ai une vie pleine et entière mais il
faut aussi donner donner aux autres
données à sa population donné à son pays
et c'est dans ce sens que je suis engagé
en politique de pittsburgh
si le candidat n'a jamais été élu il est
connu dans de nombreux milieux eau
françois joueur et coach de volée
acteurs auprès de l'adie pour
l'insertion des jeunes
alain claude magie est également
directeur de radio sud est depuis 20 ans
et dirige le comité qui défend
l'inscription de laguiole à l'unesco
le maire sortant le présente en bon
gestionnaire travailleur et discret son
successeur naturel à la mairie
[Musique]
le bras droit du maire du françois
entend poursuivre les dossiers engagés
avec la parfaite connaissance des
finances disponibles sa liste mpf
nouvelle dynamique faire alliance avec
le balisier du françois pour la
constitution de son équipe
[Applaudissements]